doch einen monat shutdown am abend fällt
die entscheidung auch darüber ob schulen
offen bleiben dürfen und mit wem an
ostern feiern kann
kräftemessen mit china wegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen verhängt die
eu sanktionen peking zahlt mit gleicher
münze zurück
wassermassen bis zum horizont australien
erlebt die schlimmsten überschwemmungen
seit jahrzehnten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten der neuen woche
und auch norbert lehmann ist dabei für
den sport
doch von mir und wieder mal beraten sie
in berlin wie es weitergeht doch statt
um 14 uhr kamen kanzlerin und
länderchefs und chefinnen erst
anderthalb stunden später zusammen
also müssen wir uns noch gedulden was
die ergebnisse dieses corona gipfels
betrifft eines aber scheint klar es wird
wohl eher auf verschärfungen stadt
auflockerungen hinauslaufen und die
große frage ist was ist mit ostern achse
konrad ein bisschen mehr familie ein
bisschen mehr verwandtschaft an ostern
diskutiert werden treffen mit bis zu
vier personen über den eigenen hausstand
kinder unter 15 jahren nicht mitgezählt
gelten würde das nur vom zweiten bis zum
15 april stichwort reisen ausdrücklich
wird davor gewarnt aber vor allem die
länder an der küste schlagen vor so
genanntes kontakt amos reisen im eigenen
bundesland urlaub also zum beispiel in
der ferienwohnung oder mit dem wohnmobil
hauptsache selbstversorgung dafür gibt
es bislang aber keine mehrheit
besser die aussichten für die bewohner
von alten und pflegeheimen die
besuchsmöglichkeiten könnten erweitert
werden für die bewohner die bereits
beide impfungen bekommen haben
knackpunkt schulen und kitas könnten
offen bleiben bis zu einer 7 tages
incidence von 200 aber nur dann wenn
mindestens zweimal die woche getestet
wird und zwar alle lehrkräfte und
schülerinnen und schüler und dann noch
dieser vorstoß nächtliche
ausgangssperren ab einer inzidenz über
100 und zwar bis 5 uhr morgens
all das nur vorschläge um die auch in
diesen minuten noch hart gerungen wird
bund und länder ringen also gerade um
lösungen um die dritte welle zumindest
abzuflachen
angesichts der rapide steigenden
infektionszahlen und incidents werte
werden die rufe nach einer notbremse
naturgemäß lauter dennoch verlangen
viele auch eine neujustierung der korona
politik die mit viel mehr tests und
impfungen den menschen mehr luft ließ
britta spiekermann
es ist schon ein ritual berlins
regierender bürgermeister müller und
bayerns ministerpräsident söder auf dem
weg ins kanzleramt die anderen landes
chefinnen und chefs zugeschaltet per
video-konferenz viel steht auf der
beratungs liste verlängerung des
schattens die infektionszahlen steigen
die maßnahmen werden härter ich würde
eher sagen dass ich im moment eher das
bewährt was wir vor einigen wochen
beschlossen haben das war eben nicht nur
ein öffnungs plan sondern das war auch
ein plan für zeiten die wieder
schlechter sind und in denen sind wir
jetzt eben leider die bundesregierung
hat sehenden auges uns in diese dritte
welle geführt sie hat hoffnungen wider
besseren wissens vorgeschlagen und
durchgesetzt
und nun ist der lockdown unumgänglich
unweit des kanzleramts am brandenburger
tor verschaffen sich kleinunternehmer
der reisebranche gehör den meisten steht
das wasser bis zum hals was sie nicht
verstehen flügel nach mallorca sind
erlaubt urlaub an der ostsee aber nicht
da passt vieles nicht zusammen sagt die
fdp
was wir brauchen ist kreative
problemlösungen vor ort testen hygiene
konzepte beschleunigung beim impfen im
turbo stadt notbremse
das erwarten jetzt die menschen von
ihrer regierung nach einem jahr pandemie
in mainz rheinland pfalz darf die
außengastronomie seit heute auf machen
doch davon ist kaum etwas zu merken wenn
der instanz wert unter 100 liegt können
gäste bewirtet werden das erste mal seit
vier monaten
doch es rechnet sich nicht heute erst ab
heute bis jetzt zwei drei stunden haben
wir auch gemacht aber leider bis jetzt
niemand darf auf bleiben oder doch
wieder zu machen
der blick richtet sich nach berlin klar
ist der shutdown wird verlängert aber
wie hart wird es kommen seit dem
nachmittag sitzen bund und länder
zusammen es wird dauern wohl bis tief in
die nacht der frage nach berlin zur theo
koll bei diesen corona gipfeln ist es ja
immer schwierig bundesregierung und 16
länder unter einen hut zu bringen
heute wohl besonders oder offensichtlich
ist braucht jedenfalls ein langes
vorgespräche im kleinen kreis wir
fordern überhaupt anfangen konnte so
massiv waren die
meinungsverschiedenheiten und auch jetzt
gibt es meldungen über eine auszeit der
kanzlerin sei das bisher beschlossene
oder
handel zu lasch ich habe selten einen
beschlussentwurf gesehen bei dem noch so
viel kontroverser die hälfte der vorlage
ist farbig und damit umstritten
umstritten ist beispielsweise die
vorgesehene kontakt lockerung über die
ostertage also eigene haushalt plus vier
erwachsenen ebenso umstritten ist ob bei
der rückkehr aus einem nicht
risikogebiet wie beispielsweise aus
mallorca dennoch eine quarantäne
verlangt werden kann und mindestens ein
ministerpräsident hat die vom kanzleramt
vorgesehene nächtliche ausgangssperre
sofort angeschossen die werde es mit ihm
nicht geben also die anlieferung unserer
politischen ostereier dürfte heute noch
etwas dauern
nun geht es ja nicht nur um die dritte
welle und den schutz der bevölkerung
sondern auch um politische interessen im
superwahljahr oder ja davon kann man
getrost ausgehen da sitzen heute einige
wichtige teilnehmer in der runde die mit
einem fuß ja schon im wahlkampf stehen
sei es bei der frage wer wird
kanzlerkandidat der union oder mit blick
auf namen der landtagswahlen wie
beispielsweise in sachsen anhalt oder
auch mit blick auf die bundestagswahl
und alle sind unter dem druck einer
pandemie müden bevölkerung für die
ostern und die osterferien hier einen
hohen emotionalen und auch entspannenden
stellenwert haben bei der kanzlerin ist
die lage etwas anders nicht nur weil sie
nicht zu den mallorca reisenden zählt
sie tritt nicht mehr an und denkt daher
vor allem in kategorien von pandemie
bekämpfen damit konnte sie sich beim
letzten mal nicht durchsetzen weil der
politische lockerungs druck ja viel zu
groß war mal sehen wie das heute ausgeht
angesichts von wieder steigenden
infektionszahlen vielen dank für die
einordnung theo koll in berlin die
dritte welle und wer was dagegen
unternehmen will darum geht es gleich im
anschluss an diese 19 uhr sendung in
einem zdf spezial und in einem zdf-
heute live sobald die pressekonferenz
beginnt
auf zdf heute.de und in unserer app
damit zu den aktuellen infektionszahlen
die steigen weiter aktuell liegt die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents bei
107 innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden
wurden laut robert koch-institut 7 1709
neuinfektionen gemeldet das sind 1105
mehr als am vergangenen montag 50
menschen starben in verbindung mit dem
virus
auch die zahl besonders schwer
erkrankter corona patienten nimmt zu
intensiv ärzte warnen vor einer
drohenden überlastung in folge der
dritten infektionswelle steigt auch bei
den belegten intensivbetten die kurve
wieder an weit mehr als 3000 corona
patienten müssen aktuell
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
derzeit seien zwar noch rund 4000
intensivbetten frei
doch ohne shutdown komme man schon
anfang mai an die kapazitätsgrenze der
energieried berichtet aus homburg an der
saar
er lag lange im koma richard gross hat
eine schwere ko geht erkrankung überlebt
mittlerweile ist das schlimmste
überstanden
sie werden das schon auch packen doch
doch und jetzt gucken wir mal wie lange
sie schon da sind 116 tage auf
intensivstationen und 111 tage an acme
eine kleine ewigkeit die ethno maschine
ersetzt die lunge reichert das blut mit
sauerstoff an sprechen kann der 59
jährige noch nicht oft gibt es bei der
ethno therapie lebensgefährliche
komplikationen nur jeder zweite
überlebte also ich kann mir das
eigentlich was jemand der 110 tage an
eco ist das kann ich mir schlimm genug
gar nicht ausmalen das ist glaube ich
eine absolute grenze erfahrung
abgetrennter sicherheitsbereich trotz
impfung brauchen die mitarbeiter
spezielle schutzkleidung das erste thema
rechnet mit mehr patienten in den
kommenden wochen zum dritten mal
wir waren ihr im gelben bereich als im
grünen und auf dauer ist das natürlich
auch keinen kein zustand
das durchschnittsalter der patienten
liegt zurzeit bei mitte 50 diese frau
ist unter 30 sie muss umgelagert werden
ein kritischer moment für eco patienten
da fast der gesamte blutfluss über die
maschine läuft bis zu sechs liter pro
minute
seit einem jahr kämpft das team um die
leben von kakerlaken eine pflegekraft
hat ganz viele augen für dinge die jetzt
ein arzt auch nicht so sieht und kümmert
sich dann um die sachen und und nur
gemeinsam kann man nun kann man solche
schwerkranken patienten auch erfolgreich
zum zum ziel irgendwie ja elf betten auf
der lungen intensivstation sind belegt
die kapazitäten begrenzt und ein ende
nicht in sicht selbst tests können mehr
sicherheit bringen erst recht an schulen
wo die infektionszahlen gerade in die
höhe schnellen niedersachsen startet
heute in eine testwoche mit selbsttests
die ersten schulen bekommen welche
schüler innen und lehrkräfte sollen üben
sie korrekt anzuwenden und zwar alle
älteren kinder in der schule im
klassenraum und dagegen gibt es massiven
widerstand
morgen ein ungewöhnlicher
unterrichtsbeginn der klasse 10b einer
gesamtschule in hannover jeder schüler
macht zuerst einen corona selbsttest
niedersachsen startet eine probewoche
mit der verteilung von test kits an
weiterführende schulen lehrer und
schüler sollen sich schon mal mit den
abläufen und herausforderungen vertraut
machen
die meisten kolleginnen und kollegen
finden wenn wir den zeitaufwand
investieren und dafür mehr
präsenzunterricht haben denn sie finden
natürlich bereit das zu machen
aber wenn ein jugendlicher positiv
getestet ist der muss gut begleitet
werden die gruppe muss muss gut
begleitet werden das kann eine lehrkraft
alleine auch mit halben gruppe nicht
lassen
das einmalige wöchentliche testen sei
nicht ausreichend lehrerinnen und lehrer
sind neben einer erheblichen überlastung
auch einer erhöhten gesundheitlichen
gefahr ausgesetzt befürchten
gewerkschaften die schülerinnen und
schüler setzen dann ihre masken ab die
sie eigentlich tragen sollen dann
hantieren sie mit wattestäbchen rom mit
test flüssigkeit und ich muss den
schülerinnen schülern sehr nahe kommen
das alles
die nicht im infektionsschutz lieber
sollen tests gleich von zu hause oder
von medizinischem fachpersonal
durchgeführt werden so lauten die
hauptkritikpunkte zum beginn der
niedersächsischen schnelltest
übungswoche auch das werden wir uns
angucken und werden das auswerten und
werden auch mit all den betroffenen mit
den verbänden mit eltern mit schülern
reden zu sagen ist es das was wir uns
vorstellen oder wollen wir auch hier an
veränderungen vornehmen die freiwilligen
selbst tests sollen die
ansteckungsgefahr im schulbetrieb
deutlich reduzieren so der plan
das ist eine zehnte klasse gewesen die
haben wir sehr diszipliniert gemacht
schwierig da ich mir das vor wenn ich
nur fünfte oder sechste klasse habe am
sichersten würden sich detlef korrekt
und seine kollegen fühlen wenn sie alle
geimpft werden wie corona krise wird
auch in diesem jahr den staat enorm viel
geld kosten
und so will finanzminister scholz im
haushalt nach liegen
für das laufende jahr plant er 60,4
milliarden euro mehr neue schulden als
ursprünglich veranschlagt das wären dann
insgesamt 240 2 milliarden euro im
kommenden jahr will scholz dann weitere
81,5 milliarden aufnehmen
erst ab 2023 soll die schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten werden
der ehemalige bayerische justizminister
sauter hat sich dem massiven politischen
druck gebeugt und ist nun doch aus der
csu fraktion ausgetreten
damit kommt sauter einem drohenden
ausschluss aus der fraktion zuvor
erst gestern hatte der 70-jährige seine
parteiämter niedergelegt hintergrund
sind korruptionsermittlungen gegen
sauter im zusammenhang mit der masken
affäre der union die wegen des
wettskandals in die kritik geratene
finanzaufsichtsbehörde bafin bekommt
einen neuen präsidenten
mark branson derzeit chef der
finanzaufsicht in der schweiz
der 52-jährige ist brite und schweizer
mit ihm an der spitze solle die bafin
mehr biss bekommen sagt finanzminister
scholz nach kritik wegen zu laxer
aufsicht über den zahlungsdienstleister
wirecard bei der bisherige bafin-chef
hochfeld zurückgetreten
diplomatie und appelle sind versandet
deshalb setzt die eu nun auf sanktionen
zum ersten mal seit mehr als 30 jahren
haben die aussenminister strafmaßnahmen
gegen china beschlossen
grund ist die unterdrückung der
muslimischen uiguren minderheit
china ist aber nicht das einzige land
gegen dass die eu wegen verletzung der
menschenrechte vorgeht
alle gerne auch in myanmar wollen die
europäischen außenminister nicht länger
zusehen wie das militär brutal gegen
demonstranten vorgeht
die eu verhängte deshalb sanktionen
gegen den hinter chef und neuen
hochrangige generäle noch heikler aber
ist der beschluss von strafmaßnahmen
gegen das mächtige china wegen der
unterdrückung der muslimischen
minderheit der uiguren in straflagern
der provinz geng yang werden vier
chinesische parteifunktionäre mit
einreiseverboten und kontensperrungen
belegt china reagiert prompt und wütend
und verweigert daraufhin zehn
europäischen politikern und
wissenschaftlern die einreise der grüne
china-experte bütikofer der selbst auf
der liste steht findet die eu-sanktionen
trotzdem richtig nicht zum beispiel
wegen handels oder investitions
interessen die menschenrechte einfachen
anstellt anscheinend ist es stark genug
das anscheinend in peking man der
auffassung ist dass man gegenmaßnahmen
einleitet also fest das glaube ich der
beste beweis dafür dass das dort
angekommen ist wo es auch ankommen
sollte es ist eine kleine sanktion aber
zum ersten mal seit dem massaker auf dem
tiananmen platz 1989 traut europa sich
gegen china vorzugehen
noch im dezember hatte die eu mit china
ein investitionsabkommen geschlossen
die sanktionen gegen china sind nur ein
trippelschritt und sie drücken sich um
die entscheidende frage herum nämlich ob
die eu sich künftig dem harten kurs der
amerikaner gegen china anschließen will
oder ob sie zugunsten der europäischen
wirtschaft den konflikt mit china weiter
scheut erinnert sich heute an
dramatische tage vor fünf jahren
töteten islamisten mit bombenattentaten
32 menschen an der metrostation mal weg
im brüsseler europaviertel wurde jetzt
der opfer gedacht unter den gästen waren
auch regierungschef fico und das
königspaar philippen und mathilde
insgesamt waren damals drei bomben
explodiert eine in der metrostation und
zwei am flughafen mehr als 300 menschen
wurden verletzt
die schlimmsten überflutungen seit
jahrzehnten erleben derzeit die menschen
im südosten australiens in einer region
in der es im vergangenen winter so
aussah waldbrände zerstörten 5,5
millionen hektar land nachdem es
monatelang nicht geregnet hatte und nun
kommt so viel wasser vom himmel dass die
fluten alles mitreißen
an der küste von new south wales rund um
sydney mussten bereits 18.000 menschen
in sicherheit gebracht werden
normen odenthal aus der entfernung sieht
man das ausmaß es ist gigantisch aus der
nähe sieht man die schicksale
sie sind dramatisch der kampf gegen das
wasser ist oft ein kampf ums überleben
keinen hund jagte man bei diesem wetter
vor die tür
diese hier müssen raus evakuiert werden
australier sind für pragmatismus bekannt
der hilft wenn nur den menschen und den
tieren nichts passiert das ist das
wichtigste
alles andere ist ersetzbar es ist
einfach bitter traurig und so viele sind
betroffen
regen regen regen in rekordmengen von
einer jahrhundertflut es die rede
die behörden haben tausende menschen
dazu aufgerufen ihre häuser zu verlassen
bevor sie von der versorgung
abgeschnitten sind durch rauskommen das
ist je nach transportmittel mal
einfacher und mal schwieriger
seit tagen geht das jetzt schon so
vielen steht das wasser längst bis zum
hals der große wahre gamba staudamm ist
inzwischen über voll viel zu viel wasser
ausgerechnet im bundesstaat new south
wales wo sie sonst ganz andere sorgen
haben gemeinden stehen unter wasser wo
vor einem jahr heftige busch brände
wüteten und dürre herrscht
ich wüsste nicht dass in unserer
geschichte schon mal solche wetter
extreme in so kurzer zeit aufeinander
gefolgt wären und das mitten in der
familie da ist kaum was das der
naturgewalt standhalten kann und noch
mehr regen ist angekündigt so kennt der
wasserstand derzeit nur eine richtung
nach oben
der schnitt und zum fußball da stehen
drei wm qualifikationsspiele für die
deutsche nationalmannschaft wir haben in
island gegen rumänien und gegen nord
mazedonien
damit beginnt sozusagen die abschieds
mission von bundestrainer joachim löw
und der zeigen sich enthusiastisch und
mit großer vorfreude so heute dfb
direktor oliver bierhoff vor den ersten
länderspielen des jahres gehen die
spekulationen um die nachfolge von
joachim löw weiter aus münchen ist
überliefert dass bayern boss rummenigge
einem wechsel von hansi flick zum dfb
eine absage erteilt hat flick darf nicht
rangnick bleibt ein kandidat und stefan
kunz rückt immer mehr in den fokus ich
kenne stefan schon lange er ist ein
starker kommunikator hat sich da
wirklich auch in diesem job gut
reingepasst hat es auch geschafft immer
wieder seine experten gut einzusetzen
insofern ist die wertschätzung für ihn
im verband sehr hoch neben muss ja vom
fc bayern gerade 18 geworden hat löw mit
florian würz aus leverkusen ein zweiter
neuling nominiert der ist sogar erst 17
jahre alt xabi alonso soll neuer trainer
in gladbach werden
nach medienberichten wird der 39 jährige
nachfolger von marco rose der gang zum
bvb wechselt der ex bayern profi war als
spanischer nationalspieler europa und
weltmeister und trainiert zurzeit die
zweite mannschaft von real sociedad
letzten samstag in rostock einen
drittliga fußball spielen mit zuschauern
doch dieses pilot modell dürfte so
schnell keine nachahmer finden
angesichts steigender kroner zahlen die
stadt leipzig etwa hat heute
entsprechenden plänen eine absage
erteilt es war eigentlich ein
vielversprechender test mit aufwändigen
hygiene konzept konnten sich nach fünf
monaten abstinenz exakt 702 zuschauer
wieder live vom spiel ihrer rostocker
mannschaft
freuen rb leipzig hatte ähnliches
angedacht 999 fans sollten zu ostern
gegen die bayern für stimmung sorgen ein
beim land sachsen beantragt das
modellprojekt doch steigende instituts
werte werden das wohl verhindern
momentan ist es völlig illusorisch in
sachsen in leipzig mit zuschauern
fußball zu stehen
es sei denn die neue schutzverordnung
lässt testläufe für modellprojekte zu
die kommt am ersten april
das war somit ja danke norbert beim
wetter wird es allmählich milder und
trockener die details erfahren sie
gleich von es denn terry so viel von uns
danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka erwartet sie um drei
viertel 10 zum heute-journal und wir
sind morgen wieder für sie da punkt 7
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit dem
zdf spezial einen entspannten abend
wünschen ihr kiez
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das aktuelle hoch
dehnt sich noch etwas weiter aus und auf
der vorderseite dieses tiefs kommt warme
luft mit und das hoch das erwärmt die
luft noch ein bisschen weiter und das
passiert in den nächsten tagen vor allem
schauen wir erstmal die kommende nacht
da gibt es regen und schnee in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen und an den
alpen sonst viele wolken ganz im westen
bildet sich nebel
teilweise klart es auch mal auf und die
temperaturen sinken bis auf minus vier
grad an den alpen minus ein grad im
vogtland und plus 5 grad an der oder
morgen im tagesverlauf noch etwas regen
und schnee richtung erzgebirge wird
allmählich weniger nördlich der elbe
viele wolken im süden vor allem im
südwesten an
auch sonnige abschnitte und das bei
temperaturen von bis zu 12 grad im
westen deutschlands
im süden liegen die werte bei fünf bis
sechs grad und die kommenden tage gehen
trocken weiter und die temperaturen
steigen nach und nach an neun bis 16
grad am mittwoch am donnerstag ebenfalls
ähnliche temperaturen im norden aber
viele wolken und am freitag zwar 17 grad
aber ganz im norden
da kommen durchaus wolken mit etwas
regen auf und damit ein schöner abend